big news we have this from scanner
cnr.com EU considers sanctioning Tucker
Carlson over interview with Vladimir
Putin officials say any sanctions would
likely require proof that Carlson is
linked directly to moscow's aggression
which is a meaningless statement because
they will just come out and be like
Tucker Carlson ran cover for Vladimir
Putin lawmakers in the EU are weighing
sanctioning news media heavyweight
Tucker Carlson as a result of his
forthcoming interview with Russian
President Vladimir Putin Gremlin
spokesman Dimitri pesov confirmed Tucker
had met and talked with Putin as did the
former Fox News anchor himself in a post
to social media platform X explaining
why he sat down with the head of Russia
EU officials are considering imposing a
travel ban on Carlson who they say is
acting as a mouthpiece for Putin quote
as Putin is a war criminal and the EU
San sanctions all who assist him in that
effort it seems logical that the
external Action Service examine his case
as well there's an important takeaway
from this I mentioned it in the
introduction to the show why would
anyone political celebrity personality
journalist why would anyone care that
Tucker Carlson interviewed the president
of a country we're not at war with are
they going to cry and complain xiin ping
came to California or came to the United
States no they don't care oh because the
reality is we are at war with Russia and
what's going on in Ukraine is just the
US using them as a proxy to go to war
with Russia we all know it everyone in
Europe knows it Chuck Schumer said we
could lose this war and so there it is
is right in front of your face the
fascinating thing is at least when we
invaded Iraq we knew that we were going
to war they said it since then I think
the Deep State The Establishment has
just figured out don't don't say you're
going to war just do it just go here we
are it's wild I mean I think with uh
sort of like we're talking about before
the rebranding of Ukraine there has also
been a a longtime narrative that Russia
is the biggest enemy we have and I think
you're right to bring up China and
especially everything all all of the the
comments about the weaker Muslims and
everything else that has gone on there
we definitely treat these two world
powers very differently um I think you
know it's obviously in my opinion Brave
and admirable that Tucker is going to
interview someone uh who is
controversial I think the fact that so
many European countries have said we're
going to try and shut Russia's access to
the Western World down both economically
and socially is disturbing I think they
are ultimately feeding a lot of
propaganda to their own people and if if
we're not at War then who what could
Putin say you know if he's such a
horrible person what is he going to say
that you think you can't refute in your
own media it's I if the Russians were
the aggressors and we wanted this war to
end then diplomacy would be good you
could go talk to him maybe he would stop
fighting but that they seem to not want
diplomacy which indicates that maybe
we're the aggressors here and it's kind
of like if I come up to you and I'm like
I'm not touching you I'm not touching
you I'm not touching you but I'm an inch
away from your face I'm aggressing on
you even though if you swap my hand away
I was the one that was aggressing on you
see I think they don't want transparency
I think you know there were all these
stories for a while Vladimir Putin is
super sick and he's going to die any
second and that will cause chaos and and
Russia is going into an election year uh
if someone were to you know speak to
Putin and say are you sick you know
maybe he'd lie but at least you would
have a western Outlet asking a question
instead of it coming telephone through
Europe I think the ultimate goal is to
make it so Russia is uh too far out of
touch to for anyone to communicate with
and so you have to rely on uh agencies
like the UN or other European you know
large scale government entities to say
this is what Russia's doing believe us
don't question it at all and by the way
if all of these news outlets really hate
state-run media so much I believe I'm
not mistaken it's the New York Times I
think CNN to The Washington Post they
take money from China Daily to run
advertisements in their papers um these
have all organizations and these
journalists have all partnered with
Chinese state-run media Outlets I'm
pretty sure Tucker said that they've
reached out um to zalinski to try to
interview him but they haven't heard
anything back but you're so right this
narrative that they're opposed to peace
talks and that you've seen at least in
whether it's the Atlantic CNN you see
op-eds all the time um and it's so
interesting one of the stories that that
we were working on at War Room a lot of
the refrain that like anti- peace talk
narrative even there's there was an opad
the title was like peace talks are quote
counterproductive which is just kind of
an asinine take in my opinion um but lot
of those people the authors behind it
you know are are luminaries the I always
say they're like the impeachment
Witnesses of Trump's first impeachment
like the Brookings Think Tank types who
you know the elites that we should trust
um but they are all fellows and advisers
at that us Ukraine Business Council but
they never disclose those conflicts of
interest in those OP EDS so part of it I
think is the ideological compromise they
really do believe that Ukraine is like
if we don't win you know Russia Russ
Russia bad um but there also is a very
clear financial interest there and I
just think it's interesting that they
never disclosed that well we have one of
the greatest tweets ever in the history
of Twitter and it is here Glenn
Greenwald tweeted who were the American
journalists who conducted even minimally
adversarial interviews with zinsky to
which Elon Musk responded to be fair
it's hard for them to talk while giving
a blow job at the same time and that may
be one of the greatest tweets ever made
and uh I had I just screenshotted it and
I had to I had to post it on X but but
as much as all all of us are laughing
and I'm sure some of you may be you know
putting ear muffs on your kids and
hoping you enough to explain to them
what that meant uh we do we we do have
this from end wokeness a very pressing
an important interview from CNN with
zalinsky of Ukraine I'd like to play for
you now this very very important
interview as a human
being so many people look up to you they
rely on you no one can imagine how hard
that is do you do you do anything for
your to yourself are you ever able to
take a minute
to to read or to listen to music or
something to sort of give yourself that
a moment I have such moments important
to be in silence to be alone and early
early in the morning when there are no
sounds sounds no people no no nobody I
mean the people people our stuff I mean
no okay well clearly I think they added
the music to that one but it is still
like wow that's like the music if the
music is really on that that's amazing
did they mess with the editing till like
get the close of her face looking sad
cuz that is cringy well I I think Rous
yeah yeah all that's an addit the
questions from Aaron Bernett that that
is really what she's asking it is the
least adversarial thing we have ever
seen and that is what they expect you as
a human being that's what you call
humanizing someone so they're humanizing
zalinski that's a tactic that's right
you kind well everyone looks up to him
so it's a very fair and even interview I
mean I I don't think I've ever looked up
to zinsky I'm going to be honest I'm not
sure who she's referencing here I you
probably look down too here we go here
we go zalinsky reveals his favorite band
that knight uh Ukrainian I'll just play
it I think I'm pretty this yo if he
likes Three Dog Knight I'm G him chance
we got add a birth control ad oh nice
thank you thank you CNN you got to pay
hey hey hey you got to pay your dues if
you want to watch CNN okay if you pay
extra and you're rich ones they won't
force feed this birth control
commercials down your throat what is
that I don't know what it was it might
not be birth control it was fizer people
look up to you they rely on you no one
can imagine how hard that is do
you do you do anything for your to
yourself are you ever able to take a
minute
to to read or to listen mus or something
to look horrible a moment I have such
moments important to be in silence to be
alone alone uh how can I be alone alone
I can be with music is through or with a
book and early early in the morning when
there are no sounds sounds in Noir no no
people no no nobody I mean the people
people our St I mean blah blah blah I
don't care to hear this I want who who's
his favorite band what is it says
classic rock did he does he name any
they want to make you watch this video I
hope Tucker asked Vladimir Putin the
same exact question for btim he's like
the be's that'd be the best no who's
going to name a Russian band this guy's
going to name a an American band or like
a European band different people
completely it's such a sop even down to
like what he's wearing right he always
has to be ready for battle he never
takes off this uniform even though when
he's traveling he's nowhere near any
Battlefield like I don't think he's ever
anywhere near the battlefield I think
this guy is a TV character he is yeah I
mean he literally was he played the
president on TV but I think he I I don't
think this guy's ever seen anything
close to conflict they they probably
have in a secure location because he's
basically uh you guys you guys have seen
Hunger Games right yeah in the second
one when they get Katniss out you know
of the games they're like keep her in
the basement have her make videos they
don't want her going to war because if
she dies she's the propaganda tool she's
a rallying cry that's what they're
trying to do with this guy I got to be
honest he's the least inspiring guy that
could have gotten I mean seriously
couldn't they have gotten some like
Dolph lungren like type Ukrainian dude
who's like filming prop propo videos on
the front line Ukrainian chick is that I
was going to say which one was HD well
they tried that with the Trans woman and
that was like but but it was to Pander
to the Liberals in the left in the
United States so they could ask for
money yeah I'll say who was Hayden paner
married to she was married to a
Ukrainian guy who was like I'm going to
the field or whatever else like much
better than Z they need like a 6'5
ripped dude who's standing there you
know holding a weapon being like as the
president I will make sure and then they
film fake videos where he's on the front
line leading the troops this is just
some guy who's in a park all the time
and he's like not doing anything well he
walks around places that seem staged and
well lit looking sort of sad and pensive
and so really in that sense he's doing
exactly what they need him to remember
remember that video that came out where
the background was completely still and
the trees weren't moving in the wind and
they were like people were like yo this
looks like a green screen and they were
no no it's not it's not a green screen
what are you talking about you don't
understand Ukraine in our culture our
trees don't move in the wind there is
Russia has stolen our W Russ the trees
can't blow because they're mad at Russia
that's the that's the state of the world
they're still in protest for the things
that we're suffering like it just
becomes so ridiculous and I think you're
right the amount of money that we're
spending on Ukraine considering this is
this is what they're doing which is just
a sort of take he has gone on so many
International trips being like please
money he's like a professional
fundraiser for his country and it seems
crazy that when Tucker Carlson is like
well I want to talk to the other side
everyone's like how could you do this
possible sanctions like you know
hysterics I just had an idea for
something I would love to make if we had
the means and it's like you take that
scene and then halfway through you just
zoom in on zalinsky and Aaron brunette
and you play like slowly increasing
romantic music with no with no dialogue
and they're just looking at each other
and then it escalates there were some
undertones right but then you have the
Dolph lungren Style guy and you will
film a different scene where he comes in
and goes zinsky get away from her She's
Mine you oh yeah it's Putin he comes in
he's like you cannot have her she is
mine and then uh it just soap opera
style you know and then Aaron berett is
like Putin you can't be here you you
died in that Safari when your brother
contracted malaria and then gave it to
you no I survived with this and then he
holds up like a golden the the the uh
the Holy Grail didn't Justin Trudeau try
to make fun of Putin he was at some
International Gathering of whoever cares
uh and there were these photos of like
Putin shirtless on Horseback that had
come out you know a little you know
whatever man like a little try hard but
okay and Justin Trudeau tried to make
fun of him for them he's like maybe we
should all take it was just like the
most ridiculous obvious jealousy uh I
just find the hysterics around this
whole thing deeply confusing and I think
ultimately trying to make Putin the bad
guy is the only way they can try to keep
the narrative going of this is something
Americans should pay attention to well
it's because we're at War if if if
Tucker Carlson interviewed like I don't
know the the president of you know
Tajikistan or something or what I don't
even do that I don't even know if they
have a president nobody would care
they'd be like uh whatever but Tucker
Carlson interviewed Vladimir Putin and
we're at war with Russia so naturally
they're freaking out I want to know why
I still want to know why we're still at
War so was it to to diminish Russia's
power or is it to take control of the
region is it both I mean it would be a
both thing well it's both like is it
really like to full military Global
dominance right now because they're
trying to do this new world order thing
where they have all of us kind of
technocratic bow to our Overlord but
like why don't they just get the US and
Russia to go along with it I don't
understand why they're making them fight
Russia's well it it could be that Russia
it's all fake conflict I don't know I
also just think it's such a double
standard I know I make everything about
about China that's the the War Room
rubbing off on me but um you know it is
really hypocritical what was it just one
or two months ago that you know you have
xiin ping right coming to San Francisco
getting the red carpet rolled out for
him and I think you make the point
precisely it's like we're basically at
at War right Russia Ukraine that's why
it's okay not that's why it's not okay
for Tucker to interview Putin so
China's obviously at war with us yeah
it's not necessarily kinetic it's more
of the unrestricted Warfare type
certainly information Warfare so then
why is it okay to have XI Jin ping on
American soil and roll roll out the red
carpet for him and have media Outlets
interview him and have them take cash
from Chinese Communist party it's just
it's such a double standard and it's
goes back to the original premise which
that it's all about narrative control
and suppression thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net